es sind bilder die auch in deutschland
viele erschüttert haben verzweifelte
menschen in afghanistan die sich nach
der machtübernahme der taliban an
startende flugzeuge geklammert haben das
war im august 2021 als die bundeswehr
nach 20 jahren einsatz in afghanistan
abgezogen ist diese überstürzte
hektische abzug diese evakuierung aus
afghanistan im august 2021 soll jetzt in
einem untersuchungsausschuss
aufgearbeitet werden der vorsitzende das
noch einzusetzen untersuchungsausschuss
ist das soll ralf stegner sein und das
ist auch der erste ring und herren die
dramatischen bilder vom abzug der
bundeswehr aus afghanistan sie nach wie
vor allgegenwärtig
die humanitäre situation vor ort
weiterhin dramatisch man kann es nicht
oft genug wiederholen 95 prozent der
bevölkerung an sich nicht ausreichend
ernähren das ist eine katastrophe die
medial kaum beachtet wird hinzu kommen
massive gewalt gegen frauen schwere
menschenrechtsverletzungen zu allem
überfluss noch das erdbeben das
mutmaßlich tausende menschenleben
gefordert hat unsere gedanken sind bei
den opfern und den angehörigen sie
brauchen unsere hilfe
afghanistan befindet sich einmal mehr in
der nächsten zellen krise wichtige
fortschritte die die bundeswehr in
zusammenarbeit mit zivilen partnern und
partnern in der internationalen
gemeinschaft bei der bildungsarbeit bei
frauenrechten über viele jahre erreicht
hat wurden durch die taliban rückgängig
gemacht wie kam es zu den fragwürdigen
lage-einschätzung zu blitzschnellen
machtübernahme der taliban und dem
hastigen abzug aus afghanistan
der deutsche bundestag hat die pflicht
für eine transparente aufklärung zu
sorgen
das gilt gegenüber unseren soldatinnen
und soldaten gegenüber den afghanischen
ortskräfte die teilweise noch heute in
bedrängnis sind sie haben die arbeit der
bundesrepublik deutschland und deutscher
organisationen institutionen jahre lang
da schützt ihn ein gilt unser großer
respekt und dank alle haben unter extrem
schwierigen bedingungen gearbeitet das
gilt auch für die zivilen helferinnen
und helfer wir müssen uns schon fragen
ob der umgang mit hilfsorganisationen
die wegen der sanktionen gegen die
taliban regime nicht ins land dürfen
obwohl sie dort dringend gebraucht
werden und nicht darsteller wichtig ist
sie bedanke mich für die entsprechend
ankündigen der bundesaußenminister dann
auch von staatssekretären heute morgen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wir haben im koalitionsvertrag haben
eine koalition festgelegt dass wir die
evakuierungs mission des afghanistan
einsatzes in einem parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschuss aufarbeiten wir
werden den zeitraum vom abschluss der
doha konferenz 2020 bis zum abzug der
internetkarte untersuchen das werden wir
parallel zu einer enquetekommission tun
insgesamt kann das helfen für zukünftige
auslandseinsätze zu lernen und wir
werden lieber kollege michael müller mit
beiden gremien so gut es geht
zusammenarbeiten auch wenn die
instrumentarien und die auftrag stellung
unterschiedlich ist diejenigen die einen
untersuchungsausschuss für den gesamten
afghanistan einsatz fordern verkennen
dass zwar manches schief gegangen ist in
20 jahren aber ein solcher zeitraum
unmöglich von einem
untersuchungsausschuss aufgaben werden
könnte es ist richtig dass mit rang
kommission zu tun meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren viele an dieser stelle
positiv hervorheben dass die union
diesen antrag unterstützt genau diesen
geister aufarbeitung werden wir brauchen
um ihr ganz konkrete aufklärungsarbeit
zu leisten denn eines ist doch klar es
ist ja auch eine besondere konstellation
regionen opposition die dazu beitragen
sollte dass dieser
untersuchungsausschuss jedenfalls kein
opposition riss kampfinstrument wird wir
haben ein gemeinsames interesse über
fraktionsgrenzen hinweg unserer
verantwortung gerecht zu werden
was heißt das konkret
erstens wir werden detailliert auf
arbeiten wirst du der problematischen
lage bewertung kam natürlich müssen wir
die frage stellen warum die
bundesregierung nicht frühzeitig mit den
drohnen machtgewinn der taliban im bilde
war wichtig ist auch die frage warum die
afghanischen streitkräfte innerhalb von
wenigen tagen von den taliban überrannt
worden lage ist eine unzureichende
ausbildung afghanischer soldaten oder
standen tatsächlich große teil der
bevölkerung hinter der machtübernahme
der taliban
hier müssen wir auch über zukünftig auch
sonst einsätze ehrlich darüber reden ob
und unter welchen bedingungen ist ein
legitimes ziel von auslandseinsätzen
sein kann eine gesellschaft in unserem
sinne umkrempeln zu wollen bzw einen
regimewechsel anzustreben zweitens wir
werden die kommunikationswege zwischen
den zuständigen ministerien innerhalb
der bundesrepublik und ihren partnern
aufarbeiten auch was die internationale
kontakte angeht eine besondere rolle
spielt die kommunikation mit den
vereinigten staaten der ex-präsident roh
maßgeblich der unkoordinierten abzug der
internationalen streitkräfte zu
verantworten hat drittens wir werden
klären müssen welche maßnahmen
möglicherweise früher hätten da köpfen
werden müssen das schließt auch
unzureichend notfallpläne für die
deutsche botschaft sowie schwierigkeiten
bei der evakuierung aufnahme von
gefährdeten ortskräfte nein denn klar
ist doch das wird möglicherweise
vielleicht sogar wahrscheinlicher weise
nicht der letzte
regierungseinsatz sein der uns drohen
könnte und es ist unsere pflicht meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren darauf
dann besser vorbeugen zu sein das sind
drei große linien werden sich der
untersuchungsausschuss annehmen wird
alles andere wie der verlauf der arbeit
zeigen einige staaten haben über uns
schon begonnen mit der aufarbeitung
deutschland ist also gefragt im
internationalen kontext
sein beitrag zu leisten in seiner zeit
einwände gebe hier im hause hat der
bundeskanzler angekündigt dass er mit
dem sondervermögen von 100 milliarden
euro endlich für eine anständige
zeitgemäße ausrüstung unserer
soldatinnen soldaten sorgen werden das
gilt für landes- und bündnisverteidigung
aber auch für die auslandseinsätze da
ist es auch unser auftrag die
erkenntnisse aus dem afghanistan-einsatz
nun in eine moderne zeitgemäße
ausrichtung unserer auslandseinsätze
fließen zu lassen lassen sie uns also an
die arbeit gehen und nach der
konstituierung und der parlamentarischen
sommerpause im sinne unserer soldatinnen
und soldaten und afghanischen
bevölkerung gemeinsam und überparteilich
diesen fragen nachzugehen dabei geht es
uns nicht primär um politische
schuldzuweisung sondern darum fehler in
der zukunft zu vermeiden wir haben die
verantwortung dafür zu klären ob alles
für unser bundeswehr und die menschen
vor ort getan wurde und ich bin froh
dass das auch interfraktionell so
gesehen wird das öffentliche interesse
am untersuchungsausschuss ist schon
jetzt sehr hoch lassen sie uns einfach
etwas gutes daraus machen viele nationen
der bundestag hinrichtet
parlamentarische untersuchungsausschüsse
immer nur dann ein wenn etwas gründlich
schief gelaufen ist die hektische
evakuierung aus kabul im sommer 2021 ist
so ein fall also warum lief die
evakuierung aus afghanistan so
überstürzt wer hat die lager so falsch
eingeschätzt und warum das also fragen
die auch formuliert werden in einem
antrag dahinter stehen nicht nur die
koalitionsfraktionen spd grüne und fdp
sondern auch die
unionsfraktion unterstützt für diesen
antrag
enthaltungen 9 der abgeordnete martin
hess hat die nach § 2 absatz 3 des
gesetzes über die parlamentarische
kontrolle nachrichtendienstlicher
tätigkeit des bundes erforderliche
mehrheit von 369 stimmen nicht erreicht
er ist damit als mitglied des
parlamentarischen kontrollgremiums nicht
gewählt da kann dann doch noch das
ergebnis der namentlichen abstimmung
schneller als erwartet also die afg
entsendet nach wie vor keinen vertreter
in das parlamentarische kontrollgremium
des bundestages dass die
nachrichtendienste kontrolliert also
jetzt weiter in der debatte die union
steht hinter diesem einsetzung antrag
hat sich mit der koalition auf einen
zeitraum und auf themen verständigt für
die union spricht johann wadephul hören
aufmerksam zu
und ich kann 99 prozent ist gesagt herr
kollege stegner unterstützen wünsche
ihnen viel erfolg
bei der arbeit in diesem
untersuchungsausschuss
zur sicherheit werden wir den kollegen
erntet wird ein als stellvertreter zu
agieren dachte folgenden hinweis geben
und mich an der stelle wirklich ganz
ernsthaft auch bei den beiden kollegen
heinrich becker und graf lambsdorff sehr
sehr herzlich für die gute
zusammenarbeit bedanken wir unterstützen
nicht ihren antrag sondern wir haben
gemeinsam diesen antrag erarbeitet und
erhält nicht unwesentliche anteile der
cdu csu fraktion denn liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der tat das muss
aufgearbeitet werden
deutsche soldatinnen soldaten aber auch
entwicklungshelfer viele
zivilbeschäftigte viele diplomaten
diplomaten haben 20 jahre lang in diesem
geschundenen land vieles getan wir haben
opfer zu beklagen bedauerlicherweise
viele tote auch aber wer noch vieles
erreicht und das möchte ich ganz
grundsätzlich zum einsatz deutschlands
nicht nur militärisch sondern auch
diplomatisch was die zivilbeschäftigten
angeht sagen und ich glaube das muss
auch uns weiterhin leiten das war
grundsätzlich ein guter ein richtiger
einsatz der sich nicht nur um
terrorismus bekämpfung gekümmert hat
sondern der in diesem land auch für
soziale verhältnisse gesorgt habt die
ein menschenwürdiges leben ermöglicht
hat und die insbesondere die frauen und
mädchen die in diesem land leider jetzt
wieder von den taliban schlecht
behandelt werden und die gefunden worden
sind die vergewaltigt und erniedrigt
worden sind dieser einsatz deutschlands
für diese menschen ist in 20 jahren gut
und sinnvoll gewesen
dennoch
die bilder des abzuges können wir nicht
vergessen und alle wir alle denken in
dieser situation an die dramatischen
evakuierungs
situationen in denen sich die menschen
dort befunden haben auch die ängste die
viele aus gestanden haben und natürlich
auch die todesopfer die der hektische
abzug gefordert hat und wir alle haben
uns damals
versprochen auch in der heißen phase des
bundestagswahlkampfes und ich finde es
ein gutes zeichen auch der deutschen des
deutschen parlamentarismus und der
verlässlichkeit des deutschen
parlamentarismus dass wir das
miteinander einhalten wir alle haben uns
damals gesagt das erste was wir jetzt
tun müssen in dieser akuten situation
ist die menschen zu retten aber wir
haben genauso eine verpflichtung als
parlament die wir immer wieder die
menschen dorthin geschickt haben das
aufzuarbeiten wie konnte es zu einer
derart dramatischen schrecklichen
situation kommen und daraus müssen wir
für die zukunft lehren ziehen deswegen
ist es richtig wir müssen das kritisch
und ohne ansicht der person des amtes
und erst recht nicht einer politischen
zugehörigkeit wirklich aufarbeiten das
schulden wir insbesondere den menschen
die wir dort in diesen einsatz hinein
geschickt haben ihre kolleginnen und
kollegen und ich möchte ganz besonders
ganz herzlich natürlich den soldatinnen
und soldaten danken die in der tat sich
in eine situation begeben haben die
außerordentlich gefährlich waren immer
wieder wird darüber nachgedacht und
spekuliert was bedeutet das in so einer
konkreten situation wirklich dann auch
sich einzusetzen und bereit sein den
dienst zu tun und die soldaten geloben
oder schwören ja auch im zweifel unter
einsatz von leib und leben das zu machen
was haben sie in dieser situation auch
getan und das ist auch ein moment des
dankes und des stolzes auf die
soldatinnen soldaten die diese
evakuierung zusammen mit anderen
hinbekommen haben und die das denen das
gelungen ist sie haben viel leid
verhindert wenn sie auch nicht den
zusammenbruch dieses regimes haben
verändern können und deswegen
machen wir diese untersuchung nicht um
irgendjemanden der dort gehandelt hat in
der akuten rettungs situation an den
pranger zu stellen sondern um
aufzuklären warum wir überhaupt diese
menschen in so eine schwierige situation
gebracht haben und das muss aufgeklärt
werden und dazu ist es auch des
parlamentarischen einsatzes aller
beteiligten
das ist gerechtfertigt und da bitte ich
die unterstützung der biete ich die
unterstützung meiner fraktion und bitte
alle herzlich sich dem anzuschließen
herzlichen dank
ein gemeinsamer antrag der
koalitionsfraktionen mit der cdu csu
fraktion zur einsetzung des
untersuchungsausschusses
der zeitraum zwischen februar 2020 und
september 2021 soll untersucht werden
zwölf mitglieder soll der
untersuchungsausschuss haben liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen kaum jemand von
uns aus den demokratischen fraktionen
der letzte legislaturperiode diesen
sommer erlebt hat wird glaube ich sie
anrufe vergessen die wir erhalten haben
die verzweiflung die bilder die wir
gesehen haben zum flughafen kabel wo
menschen ihre kleinen babys den
soldatinnen und soldaten in die hand
gereicht haben um sie nach der
machtergreifung der taliban irgendwie in
sicherheit zu bekommen und ja es gab
gravierende fehler und schlimme
versäumnisse die es aufzuarbeiten gilt
und im sinn bereits im sondierungs
papier der ampel haben wir diesen
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
versprochen und ich freue mich dass wir
heute gemeinsam mit der union hier mit
diesem
untersuchungsauftrag auch liefer und
das ist ein
untersuchungsauftrag denn der ist ja
bereit gewählt er beginnt sehr früh
schon mit den ganzen abzugsplänen von
donald trump vieles dessen vor angelegt
war was wir nachher an dramatischen
entwicklungen gesehen haben er wird sich
darum kümmern dass wir uns mit der frage
auseinandersetzen wie es zu diesem
lagebild kam auf basis welcher
informationen welche szenarien und
entscheidungen getroffen und vorbereitet
worden sind wird sich aber auch damit
beschäftigen warum trotz zahlreicher
warnungen und aufforderung im märz im
april im mai juni und juli letzten
jahres die bundesregierung teilweise
nicht gehandelt hat oder wenn sie
gehandelt hat sehr um pragmatische und
auch schwierige vorschläge gemacht hat
für die ortskräfte und für besonders
betroffene und gefährdete gruppen wie
menschenrechtlerinnen oder
frauenrechtsaktivistin und ganz ehrlich
es ist auch gut dass die frage der
abschiebungen in diesem
untersuchungsauftrag mit erwähnt ist
denn es gab kreise in der damaligen
bundesregierung die zu der zeit wo man
eigentlich hätte als es noch sicherer
war charterflüge organisieren müssen um
die ortskräfte aus dem ganzen kriegen
kriegen sich darum gekümmert haben wie
man möglichst noch taxi beflügelt in
dieser anlage organisiert das war
verantwortungslos und auch das muss
aufgeklärt werden
und dann wird es natürlich auch um die
abläufe der evakuierung gehen wo wir
auch noch mal hinschauen werden was wir
damals bewusst aus guten gründen nicht
getan haben dieser parlamentarische
untersuchungsausschuss der ist nicht nur
für uns grüne ein herzensanliegen und
eine ehrensache es auch teil unserer
verantwortung verantwortung für die
menschen in afghanistan die eben nicht
mit diesen dramatischen abzug beendet
ist und auch wenn die öffentlichkeit
nicht mehr so hinschaut und dieser
untersuchungsausschuss eben nur ein teil
der verantwortung ist ist es wichtig
dass wir mit der kommission auf die
ganzen 20 jahre engagement in
afghanistan noch mal breit ins selbst
kritisch schauen und daraus lehren
ziehen und es muss jetzt darum gehen
auch in dieser furchtbaren lage die die
menschen in afghanistan erleben nicht
nur aufgrund der regierung der taliban
der terrorherrschaft dort sondern vor
allem auch die sich zu der dramatischen
folgen des erdbebens dass wir alles tun
um die menschen dort zu unterstützen
gerade die frauen gerade die mädchen
gerade im bildungsbereich ohne die
taliban anzuerkennen und das regime zu
rechtfertigen und
teil der verantwortung ist aber auch das
was die bundesaußenministerium heute
gemeinsam mit der bundes innenministerin
angekündigt hat und ich hoffe dass den
eckpunkten im juli dann auch schnell
jetzt entsprechende um großzügige taten
folgen werden um auch das
aufnahmeprogramm endlich auf den weg zu
bringen auch das hat etwas mit den
versäumnissen des letzten jahres zu tun
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ja in
diesem untersuchungsausschuss geht es
nicht darum irgendwie vorzuführen oder
an den pranger zu stellen sondern licht
ins dunkle zu bringen und auch nochmal
aufzuklären und die wahrheit ans
tageslicht zu bringen es geht darum
prozesse strukturen und fehler zu
beleuchten und zu erkennen was man tun
muss um genau das in zukunft abzustellen
aber ja es geht auch darum verantwortung
zu benennen und deshalb möchte ich auch
noch mal am ende darauf kommen dass wir
eine verantwortung haben für die
menschen die wir in diesen 20 jahren in
dieser einsätze geschickt haben und auch
für die menschen die sich einfach so
beispielsweise im rahmen einer ngo dort
für eine bessere zukunft engagiert haben
heute ist tag des peace keeping gewann
waren eine reihe von kolleginnen und
kollegen und auch die außenministerin
die innenministerin und die
verteidigungsministerin im
bundesinnenministerium wo wir
polizistinnen und polizisten zivile
expertinnen und experten und auch
soldatinnen und soldaten für ihr
engagement geehrt haben wo sie ihre
berichte ihre motivation gehört haben
und deshalb möchte ich an der stelle
auch ganz besonders all denjenigen
danken sie sich nicht nur in 20 jahren
dort engagiert haben sondern auch
angesichts der schwierigen diskussion
die wir im letzten sommer hatten über
die rückkehr der soldatinnen und
soldaten die die evakuierungs mission
durchgeführt haben und die aus meiner
sicht nicht genug geehrt worden sind
letztes jahr haben unter den schlimmsten
und schwierigsten bedingungen sehr viele
menschen trotz aller fehler und
versäumnisse sowohl im auswärtigen amt
als auch im verteidigungsministerium in
der bundes und auch viele zivilistinnen
und zivilisten aus angeles die selbst
flüge organisiert haben dafür gesorgt
dass menschen gerettet werden und ihnen
gilt unser tiefster dank und auch heute
ist der tag das noch mal zu geben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen am ende
möchte ich mich wirklich ganz besonders
noch mal bei den kollegen bei der
kollegin heinrich bei den kollegen
lampson von lambsdorff und herrn
wadephul bedanken das war wirklich der
prozess der verhandlungsprozess mit
ihnen so wie ich nur politik im besten
sinne vorstelle grüne und fdp hatten es
da etwas leichter wir waren in der
letzten legislaturperiode in der
opposition wir mussten uns nur anhand
werdet ihr denn eigentlich liefern wenn
ihr dann regierungsverantwortung trägt
sie hatten in der letzten
legislaturperiode die
regierungsverantwortung und die
verhandlungen waren derart konstruktiv
sie haben nicht versucht irgendwas zu
blockieren irgendwie rum zu tricksen und
es ist genau eben diese vorstellung von
parlamentarismus und politik die die
menschen von uns erwarten nämlich eine
politik die sich verantwortung stellt
die fehler auf arbeitet sie für die
zukunft lernen will die auch jenseits
der so oft nervigen rollen von
opposition und koalition gemeinsam an
einem strang zieht für die menschen in
afghanistan für die menschen die wir in
die einsätze geschickt haben und deshalb
vielen dank dass wir diesen
untersuchungsausschuss so gemeinsam auf
den weg bringen können und hoffentlich
können wir genau in diesen geister auch
in diesem untersuchungsausschuss
zusammenarbeiten
ja das wird sich dann zeigen will nach
der parlamentarischen sommerpause dieser
untersuchungsausschuss seine arbeit
aufnehmen will agca hat es angesprochen
sie haben die bundesministerin auf der
regierungsbank gesehen heute gab es die
vorstellung an der zwischenbilanz ihres
aktionsplans afghanistan und da hat die
bundesministerin auch noch mal darauf
verwiesen dass 21.000 menschen aus
afghanistan nach deutschland geholt
worden sind
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
liebe zuschauer vor einigen wochen hat
die iaaf die bundestagsfraktion hier
einen antrag eingebracht zur einrichtung
eines untersuchungsausschusses
der die politischen militärischen
zivilen engagement in afghanistan
aufarbeiten sollte und zwar bei den
gesamten zeitraum des einsatzes
unser eigener antrag ist abgelehnt
worden dafür hatten sie einen anderen
antrag angekündigt der liegt uns jetzt
vor und wie erwartet befasst diese sich
nur mit der evakuierung und nicht mit
den entscheidungen die zur katastrophe
in afghanistan geführt haben die pseudo
opposition union zeichnet hiermit dass
afghanistan desaster vereint sie im
selben boot man möchte auch sagen eine
krähe hackt der anderen kein auge aus
und was für ein desaster das war 59
deutsche soldaten haben ihr leben
gelassen drei bundespolizisten
64.000 afghanischer sicherheitskräfte
43.000 afghanische zivilisten 42.000
regierungsfeindliche kämpfer millionen
von afghanen waren zur flucht gezwungen
und die totale die stabilisierung eines
kulturraums war die folge wenn ich mir
jetzt ihren antrag anschaue steht
bereits auf der ersten seite deutsche
friedensmission in afghanistan
das meine damen und herren ist blanker
hohn
eine gesamt aufklärung ist dringend
nötig jeder bürger weiß dass afghanistan
ein desaster war es muss ob aufarbeitung
gehen und nicht nur um den
katastrophalen abzug eine oberflächliche
enquete-kommission reicht hier nicht aus
ich darf unsere aus ministerin annalena
baerbock zitieren die der spd im august
letzten jahres sagte zitat anfangen bei
dem einen kann man zeugen laden und die
bereitstellung von akten beantragen bei
dem anderen werden schlussfolgerungen
für die zukunft getroffen wie sollen wir
den schlussfolgerungen für die zukunft
treffen wenn wir nicht bereit sind über
fehler der vergangenheit zu reden zitat
ende und damit hat unsere
außenministerin recht aber sie machte
einen weiteren fehler auch sie will den
untersuchungszeitraum nur auf den abzug
beschränken der ausschlaggebende
zeitpunkt für dieses desaster ist nicht
der herbst 21 sondern 20 jahre davor im
jahr 2001 zu suchen als die rot-grüne
bundesregierung den amerikanern in den
krieg folgte eine weitere interessante
fragen die zu klären wäre wäre warum
setzte die groko den einsatz vor ort
selbst als im jahr 2010 die niederländer
abzogen zwei jahre später unsere
französischen partner deutschland hätte
sich wie die niederlande und frankreich
für nationale interessen einsetzen
müssen stattdessen erzählte man sich im
berliner elfenbeinturm zwei jahrzehnte
lang märchen und behandelte unsere
deutschen soldaten die luft eine
selbstreferentielle blase welche die
eigenen werte auf die außenpolitische
lage projiziert wenige wochen vor der
desaströsen evakuierung verkündete der
damalige spd-außenminister heiko maas
eine westlich geprägte afghanische
zivilgesellschaft würde den taliban
standhalten und es gebe kein zurück in
das jahr 2001 welch hybris eine reine
realitätsverweigerung
wir täten gut daran mit anderen nationen
in einem respektvollen dialog zu treten
ohne westliche chauvinisten zu
transportieren ihre sogenannte werte
basierte außenpolitik wurde am 27 august
letzten jahres widerlegt
afghanistan ist das mahnende symbol für
das scheitern des nation building und es
ist krachend gescheitert
daran hat sich deutschland beteiligt und
es ist bitter notwendig auch aus respekt
vor den gefallenen deutschen landsleuten
eine komplette aufarbeitung
herbeizuführen die altparteien
regierungen sind dafür verantwortlich es
muss aufgezeigt werden welche fehler
hier über 20 jahre lang gemacht worden
sind da kann man sich nicht darauf
zurückziehen dass wären zu viele akten
genau das aber ist mit ihrem antrag
nicht möglich und ich sage ihnen es von
ihnen auch gar nicht gewollt weil sie
dafür die verantwortung tragen und das
ist wirklich schon tough schämen sie
sich
damit der frage ob der 20 jahre lange
einsatz der bundeswehr in afghanistan
die deutschen entwicklungsprojekte dort
sinnvolle und erfolgreich waren da
beschäftigt sich dieser
untersuchungsausschuss nicht das soll
die aufgabe einer enquetekommission sein
des bundestages die sich dafür auch
unterstützung von wissenschaftlern holen
soll
im august letzten jahres endete der
deutsche afghanistan-einsatz und es
immer wieder interessant von der af de
zu hören dass es den artikel 5 der nato
offensichtlich überhaupt nicht gegeben
hat und wir uns einen abenteuer rhein
gestürzt haben aber gut das ist eine
andere sache die bundeswehr politische
stiftungen und zahlreiche
entwicklungsorganisationen leistungen
unter schwierigsten bedingungen dort
höchstleistungen
35 soldaten der bundeswehr sind dort
gefallen
insgesamt 59 soldaten kamen nicht
lebendig nach hause und nach dem sehr
plötzlichen ende des einsatzes im
letzten sommer initiiert donald trump
sind heute die taliban wieder zurück an
der macht die unterdrückung der
freiheitsrechte und die wirtschaftliche
und existenzielle not der menschen
bestimmen jetzt dort wieder der alltag
viele fragen sich daher war dieser
einsatz und sonst ich bin sicher so
pauschal lässt sich die frage nicht
beantworten wir haben einer ganzen
generation von afghaninnen und afghanen
ermöglicht bildung demokratie und
freiheit zu erleben
wir haben die terroristischen strukturen
der al qaida zerstört und damit auch die
terrorgefahr für europa verringert
terror der lange zeit aus afghanistan
heraus koordiniert worden ist wir haben
es geschafft dort viele schulen und
straßen zu bauen
infrastruktur wie strom und
wasserversorgung sind installiert und
verbessert worden wir haben zwei
jahrzehnte genutzt um gemeinsam mit den
afghanen an einer besseren zukunft zu
arbeiten der deutsche einsatz in
afghanistan endete im letzten jahr aber
chaotisch der schnelle abzug
insbesondere unserer us amerikanischen
partner überrascht hat die damalige
bundesregierung
der vormarsch der taliban wurde von
unseren zuständigen ämtern und
nachrichtendiensten krass falsch
eingeschätzt mit katastrophalen folgen
die kampfkraft der afghanischen armee
wurde von deutschen dienststellen viel
zu positiv eingestuft diejenige der
taliban viel zu schwach bewertet und die
darauf folgende bilder des juli und
august 20 21 haben uns alle tief berührt
taliban die brutal und schnell das land
einnehmen menschen die um ihr leben
bangen und das land hastig verlassen
wollen horden von menschen die sich vor
dem flughafen gegenseitig erdrücken aus
angst um ihr leben bombenanschläge in
diese menschenmassen hinein babys die
über den stacheldrahtzaun hinüber
gereicht wurden um den kindern eine
zukunft zu ermöglichen panische räumung
von botschaften ortskräfte die uns
vorher vor ort unterstützt hatten und
die uns nun um die rettung ihres lebens
an flehten dies alles darf sich nicht
wiederholen und wir müssen jetzt die
richtigen lehren daraus ziehen
als fdp-fraktion haben wir früh darauf
hingewiesen dass jeder einsatz der
bundeswehr eine strategie braucht und
regelmäßig evaluiert werden muss wir
müssen uns immer im voraus fragen was
wollen wir erreichen bis wann wollen wir
es erreichen und wann kann die aufgabe
erfüllt sein und wo ist der zeitpunkt
für einen abzug erreicht diese fragen
wurden dem fall afghanistans aber gar
nicht bestellt und das gipfelte im chaos
und kabul im sommer 20 21 als parlament
stellen wir uns dieser verantwortung und
arbeiten die vergangenheit auf um daraus
für die zukunft zu lernen wir wollen
fokussiert auf den zeitraum februar 20
bis september 21 untersuchen und dabei
werden wir der frage nachgehen welche
erkenntnisse die bundesregierung hatte
welches entscheidungsverhalten und
handeln fand in der bundesregierung
statt wir fokussieren uns dabei auf die
entscheidung in zusammenhang mit dem
abzug der bundeswehr und weiterer nato
kräfte der diplomaten sowie der
evakuierung von menschen aus afghanistan
und es geht uns dabei nicht um pure
schuldzuweisungen daher werden wir
ergänzend eine enquetekommission
einsetzen und so stellen wir sicher dass
wir auf der einen seite parlamentarisch
untersuchen die konkreten versäumnissen
und fehlern aus den letzten jahren und
gleichzeitig aber die lehren ziehen für
zukünftige bundeswehreinsätze der
bundesrepublik und die ergebnisse des
untersuchungsausschusses und der kommt
in kommissionen werden von großer
bedeutung ein für unser zukünftiges
engagement der brutale angriffskrieg
russlands auf die ukraine hat uns
gezeigt wie schnell frieden und
sicherheit gefährdet sein können hier
bei uns in europa und es ist daher von
größter bedeutung dass wir
reaktionsfähig sind dass wir krisen
meistern können dass alle relevanten
ministerien behörden und akteure
miteinander abgestimmt und
handlungsfähig sind und dass wir ein
klares politisches verständnis
unserer ziele auch artikulieren
daher begrüße ich ausdrücklich die
erstellung einer nationalen
sicherheitsstrategie
diese fortschritts koalition bekennt
sich zur verantwortung deutschlands in
der welt für unseren beitrag zur
stabilität und frieden zur
aufrechterhaltung des internationalen
völkerrechts die einsetzung dieses
parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschusses unterstützt
diesen auftrag und daher bitte ich um
ihre unterstützung für den auftrag
vielen dank
als nächstes erhält das wort für die
fraktion die linke die abgeordnete sevim
dagdelen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
nach 20 jahren krieg in afghanistan
wollen spd grüne fdp und union die 20
jahre lang die hand für diesen krieg
gehoben haben einen
untersuchungsausschuss einsetzen was sie
aber auf keinen fall wollen ist eine
umfassende aufarbeitung ihrer
beteiligung am krieg in afghanistan und
sie verweigern dies weil sie sonst aus
dem mörderischen desaster des krieges am
hindukusch konsequenzen ziehen müssten
und das wollen sie nicht sie wollen so
weitermachen wie bisher deshalb soll
sich auch der untersuchungsausschuss
damit gar nicht beschäftigen sondern nur
mit dem chaotischen abzug und der
evakuierung durch die bundeswehr dabei
gäbe es vieles mehr zu untersuchen und
ich spreche jetzt nicht von den ganzen
krieg lügen mit denen sie hier 20 jahre
lang den krieg gerechtfertigt haben
obwohl sie wussten dass die bundeswehr
weder zur frauenbefreiung noch zum
brunnenbohren an dem blutigen gemetzel
beteiligt war gespräche von den
200.000 getöteten afghaninnen und
afghanen
von den 59 toten bundeswehrsoldaten die
ihr leben in diesem sinnlosen abenteuer
verloren haben von den immensen
kriegskosten von über zwölf milliarden
euro die deutsche gesellschaft
gesellschaft zu schultern hatte all das
soll nicht untersucht werden da sagen
wir was für eine farce und auch die
zahlreichen kunst für welche ihrer
engsten verbündeten rufe nach aufklärung
untersuchung und ahndung aber
stattdessen soll jemand wie der
journalist julian assange denn nicht nur
kriegsverbrechen der usa im irak sondern
auch ihre nato verbündeten in
afghanistan publik gemacht hat lebendig
begraben werden und die bundesregierung
gibt sich auch hier wieder weg und wir
als linke sagen ganz klar nicht mehr
kriegsverbrechen auf deck gehört ins
gefängnis sondern der sie begeht oder
wie viele
afghanische kleben
afghanische leben zählen einfach nicht
sie sind ihnen den
untersuchungsausschuss nicht wert und
kommen sie mir nicht damit dass dies in
einer m cat kommission aufgearbeitet
werden könnte diese interfraktionelle
arbeitsgruppe soll den umfangreich und
bedeutsamen sach komplex lösen sie
wissen dass das nicht stimmt ein
untersuchungsausschuss hat ganz andere
instrumente und möglichkeiten als eine
in kat kommission die waffe ordnete das
erlauben seine zwischen die wahrheit ist
das wort geordnete ich möchte sie etwas
fragen erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage
von frau strick zu mama alles klar die
wahrheit ist dass sie sich bereits nach
neuen kriegen umschauen in der sahelzone
und anderswo wer ernsthaft meine damen
und herren an aufklärung und
konsequenzen interessiert ist darf
jedenfalls den untersuchungsauftrag
nicht auf die tage des abzugs der
bundeswehr
beschränken der abzug so chaotisch
erwarb war nicht der grundfehler sondern
das waren die 20 jahren krieg in
afghanistan
die linke war von anfang an von anfang
an gegen diesen krieg wir als linke
wollen einen untersuchungsauftrag der
die gesamte zeit des afghanistankriegs
umfasst und er die begangenen
kriegsverbrechen nicht einfach
ausblenden
aber das ist offensichtlich der grund
warum all die parteien sich über diesen
untersuchungsauftrag geeinigt haben im
vorfeld dieser debatte die 20 jahre dann
ja gesagt haben zu diesem krieg und
diejenigen die dann gesagt haben zu
diesem krieg einfach ausgeschlossen
wurden aus den beratungen ist sehr
abgehen dann
begeben da drin war das für die linke
die sprecherin für internationale
politik ihrer fraktion nächster hier
ist jorg nürmberger für die
sozialdemokraten
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich hätte die bitte wenn die afg und die
linke ihre ideologischen scheuklappen
ablegen würden dann könnten sie erkennen
dass die einsetzung von
enquete-kommission und
untersuchungsausschuss parallel hier in
diesem fall sachgerecht ist und 20 jahre
lang haben deutsche soldatinnen und
soldaten in afghanistan gedient haben
sich entwicklungs kräfte journalistinnen
und journalisten frauenrechtlerin und
frauenrechtler und viele andere personen
für menschenrechte und eine
demokratisierung des landes eingesetzt
es war eine der wohl anspruchsvollsten
missionen und sie endete nicht mit einem
koordinierten abzugs verfahren sondern
mit einer elftägigen evaluierungs
operation durch das auswärtige amt und
vor allem durch die bundeswehr die
dramatischen bilder aus dem vergangenen
sommer sind uns allen in erinnerung
geblieben menschen die auf dem flughafen
kabul versuchten sich einen der wenigen
plätze in einem der evakuierungsflüge zu
sichern durch den fall von kabul hatte
sich die sicherheitslage in afghanistan
schlagartig verändert und eine sofortige
evakuierung des personals der deutschen
botschaft deutsche staatsbürgerinnen
sowie betroffene ortskräfte wurde
unumgänglich und musste quasi von heute
auf morgen vorbereitet und durchgeführt
werden was die bundeswehr im rahmen
dieser evakuieren geleistet hat verdient
unseren größten respekt um 16 bis zum 26
august 21 wurden mehr als 5300 40
schutzsuchende über eine luftbrücke der
bundeswehr in sicherheit gebracht für
diese leistung möchte ich mich an dieser
stelle ganz ausdrücklich bei unseren
streitkräften sowie allen anderen daran
beteiligten ausdrücklich bedanken
offensichtlich heute die frage wie es
überhaupt zu dieser unerträglichen
situation kommen konnte und genau diese
frage müssen wir dringend beantworten
bereits in unserem koalitionsvertrag und
es wurde mehrfach darauf hingewiesen
haben wir festgehalten wir evakuierungs
operation in einem
untersuchungsausschuss aufzuarbeiten und
hier stellten wir uns als spd und damit
als mitglied der damaligen
bundesregierung selbstverständlich
unsere verantwortung in einem
gemeinsamen antrag lieber herr dr
wadephul der koalitionsvertrag
fraktionen und der cdu csu fraktion
haben wir nun die genauen details für
die arbeit in diesem
untersuchungsausschuss festgehalten ziel
des untersuchungsausschusses wird es
sein den gesamten abzug aus afghanistan
aufzuarbeiten der untersuchungszeitraum
ist wie auch bereits erwähnt zwischen
dem duo abkommen vom februar 2020 und
dem tatsächlichen abzug im september
2021 wir werden unseren rahmen dieser
arbeit intensiv mit den fehlern die in
diesem zeitraum gemacht wurden
auseinandersetzen und wollen vor allem
die folgenden fragen beantworten warum
war die bundesregierung nicht frühzeitig
und nicht ausreichend über die lage im
land und die bevorstehenden zugewinne
der taliban informiert warum gab es zu
dem zeitpunkt als die grünen an geworden
angeordnet wurde offenbar nur
unzureichende notfallpläne unter anderem
mit der folge dass zum beispiel akut
gefährdete ortskräfte mit dem abzug der
bundeswehr weiterhin in afghanistan
verbleiben mussten im detail haben wir
dazu eine liste von 40 offenen fragen
von denen ich hier nur einige beispiele
nennen möchte wir werden klären müssen
wie erfolgte der abstimmung zwischen den
betroffenen häusern und welche
absprachen gab es mit nato verbündeten
insbesondere den usa welche
schwierigkeiten und verzögerungen gab es
bei der evakuierung und bei den
prozessen zur identifizierung und
aufnahme der gefährdeten ortskräfte wie
intensiv war die gewinnung und wie
zuverlässig war der austausch dieser
nachrichtendienstliche informationen die
herr vorlagen für alle diejenigen die im
rahmen der friedensmission in
afghanistan leib und leben riskiert
haben müssen wir genau diese antworten
eben das betrifft eben auch den umgang
mit den lords kräften die deutschen
stellen über zwei jahrzehnte treue
dienste geleistet haben dabei geht es
uns keinesfalls darum ein tribunal
abzuhalten oder über einzelne akteure
den stab zu brechen viel mehr wollen und
werden wir objektiv die geschehnisse und
fehler aufarbeiten und die bereits
genannten fragen beantworten wir werden
also auch ein blick in die zukunft
richten um schlüssel für künftige
evaluierungsmissionen zu ziehen und so
aus unseren eigenen fehlern zu lernen
eine eigene aufarbeitung der
evakuierung ist daher in richtung
unserer internationalen partner ein
wichtiges signal dass auch wir unseren
beitrag zur aufklärung der ereignisse
leisten und dass wir bei zukünftigen
gemeinsamen friedensmissionen ein
leistungsfähiger partner sein werden ich
gehe davon aus dass die betreffenden
ministerien nach das bundeskanzleramt
inklusive des bnd die notwendigen
unterlagen dem parlament entsprechend
war zur verfügung stellen und uns bei
unserer arbeit unterstützen ich freue
mich daher auf eine intensive und am
ende erfolgreiche zusammenarbeit im
untersuchungsausschuss um aus den dort
so gewonnenen erkenntnissen die
notwendigen maßnahmen ergreifen zu
können damit wir künftig besser auf
ähnliche situationen vorbereitet sein
werden vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
jorg nürmberger wahl ist für die spd
fraktion ja es war der grösste
evakuierungseinsatz der bundeswehr
5347 menschen flog die luftwaffe aus
kabul aus nachdem die taliban die macht
übernommen hatten insgesamt das hat ja
bundesaußenministerium berbalk heute
nochmal gesagt sind 21.000 menschen
aus afghanistan nach deutschland
gekommen in den letzten monaten
schicksalsschlag für dieses geschundene
land ich möchte den vielen hunderten
familien die angehörige verloren haben
mein mitgefühl ausdrücken und hoffe dass
trotz der schwierigen politischen lage
die bundesregierung monetäre
unterstützung und katastrophenhilfe
leisten kann die ankündigung am heute
auch vernehmen können meine damen und
herren eine katastrophe ist es wahrlich
auch was sich mit der machtübernahme der
taliban im letzten august in afghanistan
abgespielt hat viele errungenschaften
auf den letzten 20 jahren sind damit auf
einen schlag zerstört worden und wenn
man hier von links und rechts vernehmen
muss dass letztendlich die
terroristische gefahr die von al qaida
2001 ausgegangen es auch für europa dann
kann nur der hinweis gelten dass man
sich hier noch mal eindringlich mit den
details womit der geschichte letzten 20
jahren auseinandersetzen sollte was den
abzug betrifft haben wir sicherlich noch
alle die bilder vor augen von den
menschenmassen am flughafen von der
angst in den gesichtern der menschen und
von kleinen kindern die von ihren
verzweifelten eltern über die
absperrungen gehoben wurden das geht
einem nahe und natürlich haben wir uns
alle der abschluss seine 20-jährigen
militäreinsatzes anders vorgestellt was
auch hier deutlich werden muss unsere
bundeswehr hat diese schwierige und
gefährliche mission die aufträge die
auch wir als parlament hier gegeben
haben umgesetzt und dafür sind wir
unseren soldatinnen und soldaten von
ganzem herzen dankbar
wenn wir unseren dank ausdrücken dann
gehören natürlich immer auch die
gedanken an die dazu die nicht mehr zu
ihren familien heimkehren konnte meine
damen und herren dass es so kam wie es
gekommen ist ist vor allem eine
politische niederlage und deswegen ist
es wichtig dass wir bei der
rettungsoperation die politischen
rahmenbedingungen und entscheidungen
konsequent aufarbeiten reflektieren und
daraus schlüsse für die zukunft ziehen
in deutschland in der welt verantwortung
übernehmen will dann müssen wir auch ein
leistungsfähiger und verlässlicher
partner sein und deshalb müssen wir uns
die frage stellen ob unsere strukturen
genügen um zukünftig solche situationen
zu vermeiden die debatten zur nationalen
sicherheitsstrategie und auch über einen
nationalen sicherheitsrat sind hier
sicher ein schritt in die richtige
richtung
heute knapp ein jahr nach dem abzug ist
die frage der evakuierungen immer noch
nicht abgeschlossen das schicksal der
immer noch in afghanistan befindlichen
worts kräften ihrer familien muss uns
jeden tag antreiben schneller und besser
zu werden es ist nämlich fundamental
dass wir die ortskräfte die unsere
arbeit vor ort erst ermöglicht haben
nicht hängen lassen was wäre auch ein
schwieriges signal an die ortskräfte in
den anderen einsatzländern meine damen
und herren ja dieser abzug muss
aufgearbeitet werden hat er doch für
viele menschen und auch für unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten eine hohe
gefährdung verursacht ich komme zum
schluss präsidentin die einsetzung des
untersuchungsausschusses
auf basis eines gemeinsamen antrags von
vier fraktionen ist deshalb richtig und
ich freue mich auf die zusammenarbeit
und darauf dass wir über
fraktionsgrenzen hinweg ausarbeiten was
wir in zukunft besser machen können
herzlichen dank
thomas endl war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion er soll
stellvertretender vorsitzender dieses
parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschusses zum afghanistan
abzug werden vorsitzender sonja ralf
stegner für die von der spd werden
letzter redner jetzt patrick schnieder
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen sehr
geehrte damen und herren meine vorredner
haben zu inhalt und genese des auftrags
und
dem was wir mit diesem antrag hier
erreichen wollen dass wesentliche gesagt
ich möchte deshalb einige anmerkungen
zum verfahren noch machen wir werden ja
voraussichtlich das an den
geschäftsordnungsausschuss dann nach
gängiger praxis erfolg über weise noch
gestatten sie mir zuvor noch eine
bemerkung zu dem was wir von der
extremen auf der linken und rechten
seite gehört haben da sagt ja sagt
schwadroniert die asd von einem
angeblich respektvollen dialog so
wörtlich der hier geführt werden soll
und das was dann inhaltlich damit
verbunden wird ist nicht nur destruktiv
sondern das genaue gegenteil und die
linke ist sich nicht zu schade dass
nicht mehr im duktus aufzugreifen sie
hätten gemeinsam diesen antrag hier
einbringen können da wächst wieder
zusammen was zusammengehört die beiden
end eines hufeisens und das was sie hier
was sie jetzt wieder hier an lärm
verursachen bestätigt ja nur dass das
richtig ist dass wir sagen sie sie eint
ihre einmal das nie an einer diskussion
die an der sache orientiert ist
überhaupt kein interesse haben dass sie
an einer parlamentarischen untersuchung
gar kein interesse haben es ist
sachgerecht dass wir das was im letzten
sommer passiert ist in einem
untersuchungsausschuss aufklären und
diesen gesamten einsatz der ja nicht nur
negativ bewertet werden kann sie nehmen
übrigens schon schlussfolgerungen voraus
die sie in einem untersuchungsausschuss
ja angeblich erklären wollen und deshalb
ist das vollkommen sachgerecht was wir
vorhaben in diesen beiden gremien das zu
bearbeiten und es auch sachgerecht dass
die opposition dass wir an diesem
untersuchungsauftrag mitwirken ich bin
dankbar darüber dass wir mit den
regierungsfraktionen das so hinbekommen
haben die haben über zwei jahrzehnte
gemeinsam politisch diese mandate
getragen deshalb ist es auch sinnvoll
dass wir gemeinsam den
untersuchungsausschuss einsetzen wir
wollen ich will das noch einmal betonen
und herausgeben wir wollen aus den
fehlern lernen
wir wollen für die zukunft lernen wir
wollen die nötigen schlussfolgerungen
ziehen das steht im mittelpunkt dafür
ist auch dieses gremium der richtige
ansatz
möchte mich sehr herzlich bedanken für
ein faires verfahren wir waren im grabe
in den verfahrensfragen nicht in allen
punkten einig gab decency oder da und es
ehrt auch die regierungsfraktionen dass
die union mit ihren auffassungen sich
dort an den einzelnen stellen
durchsetzen können konnte was die größe
des ausschusses angeht mit zwölf
mitgliedern damit wir spiegelbild nicht
abbilden wie das plenum zusammengesetzt
ist aber auch hinsichtlich des
verfahrens mir es richtig zu sagen wir
wollen kein hauruck verfahren der
respekt gebietet es dass wir hier in
einem ordentlichen verfahren jetzt auch
unter einbeziehung des geschäfts
ordnungsausschusses dort vorankommen
deshalb meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
noch einmal herzlichen dank an alle die
konstruktiv hier mitgearbeitet haben ich
hoffe dass die weiteren beratungen die
anschließende arbeit des
untersuchungsausschusses in diesem
geister auch weitergeführt wird das wäre
ein gebot des respekts gegenüber den
soldatinnen und soldaten der bundeswehr
gegenüber den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern der beteiligten ministerien
aber auch gegenüber den menschen in
afghanistan
patrick schneider war das letzte redner
hier zu diesem tagesordnungspunkt heute
allerdings wird dieser
untersuchungsausschuss noch nicht
eingesetzt patrick staates angedeutet
dass formale verfahren ist ja so dass
der antrag erst mal in die ausschüsse
überwiesen wird und dann in der nächsten
das ist übrigens auch die letzte
sitzungswoche vor der parlamentarischen
sommerpause also in 14 tagen dann hier
beschlossen werden soll und dann konnte
sich konstituieren kann und dann seine
arbeit nach der parlamentarischen
sommerpause aufnehmen kann parallel soll
es ja eine enquete kommission geben die
dann über diesen ganzen afghanistan
einsatz befindet die da liegt allerdings
noch keinen antrag auf einsetzung vor
aber wie gesagt die beiden gremien
werden dann ja auch erst nach der
parlamentarischen sommerpause ihre
arbeit aufnehmen so